[Music]  few shots in modern cinema are as iconic  as a motorcycle slide shot from akira  the 1988 cyberpunk anime masterpiece the  shot has been parodied and outright  mimicked numerous times over the decades  since the film was first released did  jordan peel miss an opportunity to use  it for his newest film  no  well racing away from the alien emerald  performs the iconic slide in addition to  being a reference to akira the shot is  also the payoff to align from the  beginning of the film when emerald is  giving her speech to the crew of hul's  film early on she mentions that she  rides motorcycles presumably she's also  an anime fan with good taste